you
all righty let's see what we get small
crew 25 in there five seconds four three
two one here we go
we have HS 960 arena created tournament
three o 55-minute tournaments
what's unprotected this guy I don't see
how he could be struck out too soon not
a knight wow what an arrangement I might
want to do this hmm okay yeah I'll go
with that and game on wow this is a
really tough arrangement to work with if
I try to fianchetto where would the
knight go
yeah well maybe I should still do this
to restrict the night
oh boy
here's another thing maybe now if I do
this a bishop here could be a killer let
me start with this move
to do this and then if there's a bishop
check one day I could play Knight here
work with the small pawn Center
wow this is a really okay that's a bit
of an odd move not too soon hmm and it's
a pretty committal move I'm going to
hold off on that I guess I'm going to go
here and then I'm not going to try to
fianchetto I guess I'll go for this kind
of stuff okay I'm starting to see a path
forward this night I'll have to move
again got to play a little bit quicker
so we're going to take away this square
and open a door for the bishop
these guys can now come out on leaning
towards going Queen side excuse me
Castle kingside these two the bishops
need to move in order to Castle kingside
and yeah so if I do this there's night
here
it's a bit irritating
maybe now I get this pond rolling
here maybe even this tough arrangement
let's start with Bishop here
I really don't know you know
would follow up with that
maybe here
yeah let's let's keep this I want to
keep the
over this square also my time I do not
have used to playing 504 chess960
[Music]
they may be
have some space but I still think I need
to hold my ground it's my sea pond now
that
going to try to influence this maybe I
get this and this is a I think is strong
Deitrick threat playing e5 and then I
could anchor Knight quickly in this
weakest Square and whites camp
there is d5 can also just push the pawn
could jump here let's see what might
Knight could do that's dangerous here he
might he should maybe have some
possibilities once he's on g4 hmm okay
no no they can't even play off for just
running it like that so now I'm gonna
close shop and now he's my bad Bishop so
I'm going to be really quick to activate
him I like that I may have to give up my
good Bishop for this night let's still
look at exchanging my dark square bishop
let's do right now I stopped the f4 idea
good versus bad Bishop position just
like that so I want to keep this tension
I might Castle queenside um it's going
to look weird but I want to get my Queen
here
that move interesting
we're going to have some mass exchanges
and in the end I have this now let's get
my queen here and then here I'm still
playing with this idea of the good good
versus bad Bishop Bishop back to d6 I
can still castle on either side good
harmony with my structure and Bishop
Bishop here maybe I don't even castle I
go king c7 I don't know it's all for
Queen exchange give them a connected
past pawn but I don't want to take like
this because it allows some entry points
giving them a strong pawn here but now
let's see what good things my King could
do from d6
let's find out
break
let's do it now
the file even on the clock so I'm
looking for us to create some target now
this is the sheep on Derby pond there at
the 22nd mark would still go where's
this
takes and then rook here
and maybe I can force them to take me
and this pond will become vulnerable and
here that will drop this pawn bishop
here you take my rook and now he's a
target
let's put pressure on them
try to flush this
ship back and now he's close to trapped
actually here in the mission of stuck
yeah you have to give up a pawn now
defend this guy and then pick him up
there in pre move mode whoo yeah that
one came down to good versus bad bishop
type ending
they may have added may have had an
opportunity there to play e5 before I
played f6 just to rattle the structure
and create a a past deep on in a
position where there were still some
where there was still a lot of fuel on
the board the Queen's are still on the
board and my King was still in the
middle but yeah they didn't go for that
all right so this one feels like it's
much more natural these Knights could
find some nice posts here and the
bishops I feel like they're just already
fee and cut out vol knurl points are the
RIP pawns here
I think I like that move as well rook in
the center pawn in the center
he rocks
Center so that's my bad guy so yeah
probably this stuff here's a little trap
g6 queen takes Bishop g7 Queen takes
pawn rook h8 queen is cooked let's start
with the knight here
I could castle
actually we both could have capsuled on
move one
all right you're gunning for this move
so make that a little bit difficult to
get in let's let's let my life squared
bishops presence be felt right now
so I'm fighting for control over a four
one two supporters they castled I might
want to strike at this pawn now
let's do that yeah I have enough support
this if I need some more this is fine
yeah I think what was maybe more
important is to take up a a presence in
the center a good pawn presence in the
center before going with the routine
like moves like castles I think I'm now
in a position to just castle let's let's
just do it
much more natural-looking here than the
last game
even on the clock first time playing
against this opponent Stephen 1745 okay
let's see what Stephen throws at me okay
I go here I don't see any issue with
that but you know what my bishop needs
to see so let's keep his eyes open still
maybe I go here in some lines but I
definitely can't do without g6 lamo
tempted to take
let me take let's go to keep that
tension
and I'm going to take I don't want to
end up with some kind of hanging pawn
structure
I think both are good knight c6 it's
probably the computer move okay so I
have a two-to-one in the center now that
they captured with the piece and E 5 is
a possibility at some point but I don't
see any rush where it's doing that
let's get another piece out
I would really like a light square
bishop exchange and then I could key in
on these holes h6 or h3 and F string
many players with a couple games already
in there good move suppose I go here
let's just force my opponents hand on
this I'll take with the Queen if I take
with the bishop there's a fork
hmm
alright let's let's take and now I want
to get my LightSquared Bishop playing a
far more productive role so on this I
have this move I'll gladly give this guy
up so he's my bad bishop
for this stuff okay so I have this
opportunity let's let's try for this
still going with this uh
theme here I'll give him up
this so structure tying in well it's my
bishop I got to go a little bit faster
see if they go for a queen exchange also
getting out of the way so I have rook to
see a try to restrict their bad bishop
clamp down on this advance okay let's go
with this rook because maybe something
cracks open over here on the B and C
files this is a slight improvement
let's stay out of this dog and I'll
actually Rick's the Aether's c4 rook c6
or c4 so let's play this first here
hangs the pond yeah they just hung upon
there and now this structure here kills
the bishop there's no fear of c4 now I
can eventually challenge that bishop
let's do this first I don't want him to
get super glued into c5 and let's double
up they're asking to yeah I'll be able
to take advantage of this pin soon here
here I could put all my pieces on this
even on the clock 20 seconds each collet
and throw one last one in there and
we're going to win another pond
up it's a color bishop position winning
the exchange now yeah they resigned
they're in a tough spot okay
41 minutes left
thank you for that Windex Ian and thank
you
the sub man just read your no 25 seconds
I guess we'll start with don't know make
a move I wish there was a countdown just
a little countdown and both Knights are
cornered can I get this in form upon duo
who f4
f4 f5 e 5d6
don't know that i can reinforce that
point might be too soon to do this
clean here might be something kind of
watch out for that who
Oh
[Music]
here already drops the exchange Wow okay
I'm gonna do this
let's see if they go in for this try to
challenge my pawn duo okay now
probably grab some space huh yes so
we're going to do this and then probably
this and he's going to be my bad guy
tried to solve him let's see if I could
get this in I have a little bit of
kingside space and I'm able to get this
in before they go here and
position what was I just saying okay
he's protected though
with this clean exchange is there a
night that's going to arrive here
anytime soon
okay which pond doesn't matter
I got this one I guess
okay that
you
my light-square bishop sway out is like
this maybe I should have kept this up I
do open and gone here instead okay hang
on let's put my knight here
here here and then here but I don't want
to be too quick to jump in there I've
wasted a lot of time I just have to play
got to play fast now I would love to see
a bishop check because now that's that's
do good bishop
that's their good bishop so Bishop to d8
is a desirable thing I should have gone
here so on Bishop takes at least I'm
recapturing and moving forward hello
just dropped their Bishop in their night
dominoes
oh well that was super helpful yeah
maybe they're too fixated on the clock
or something I'll take him
and keep them there also had this
yeah
fast
okay
structure and I guess we're going to be
playing this one out got three pass
bonds and we got a fork here yeah
well it was an interesting start and
then clearly drop the bishop and drop
the house let's push them away alright
they resigned I got eight as
is up there in first Christopher Walken
is in there we played in the uh yeah
where we're playing we're playing in the
three check so Christopher Walken is a
three check player at least and a 960
player queen master is right there on my
heels all right Billy Taylor this
protected so the Queen can immediately
strike at the Queen and Bishop can
strike at these two points that are
unprotected a way to defend both is
night here though
they're going to make a move and we have
25 seconds to do it
oh they didn't have I don't know what
happened there huh oh my god I'm playing
as Rory
oh my god what am i doing good grief
what a bonehead play you're playing his
weight ah man
I was so lawful
I was just saying they're going to lose
on time oh man oh that is so terrible oh
man I don't know what I was thinking I
don't know man man man ah some -32 I'm
like what
ah
oh man try to anticipate what they're
gonna do and I'd even make my first move
whoops whoops that's a big whoops ah man
oh man
ah okay
let's go here gotta activate
Bishop ah ma'am
okay
whoo my nights are struggling neither
home sits on a good square
let's start with that
I'm looking at c4 possibly that bothers
me so much that I
I played a game like that where I just
didn't even make a move back
to basics what color are you playing
maybe I could have held off on the
bishop move because I'm assuming they'll
have to make that move anyhow and I
probably better to take that bishop in
one move let's stop the knife from
getting active maybe he wants to go
there
let's go here
oh that's a tough one
lose man tough
I'm controlling both nights Wow
all right let's go here I guess they
really want to play this advanced okay
how about this yeah my night on 83
should try to get this advanced in like
a Castle kingside yeah as soon as I move
the bishop I could have counseled King's
side
let's get there
just get on with this advance I have
enough support
four one two three four one two three
four attackers I'm enough support
and how to take and see what the pond
yeah it's raining a fork now on this
advance trying to
advantage of my fiend kettle tonight I
can always insert this first it's
probably castle let's get castle put the
rook on d8 d1 and shoot for a d5 advance
now let's try this
their king is right in the middle so
I kind of also captured here I didn't
consider that it since the night mode
but this is fine let's break those pawns
off clean exchange I'm fine with okay
let's push secures my Queens post don't
fall for this here any any pawn move I
have a knight to b5 I feel like I just
want to push again so I don't get
blockaded now I don't have to do that
though my knight controls this my queen
and Knight are are doing a good job this
Knight is stupid this Knight is hanging
this Knight is hanging we're going to
put them here and go for a sacrifice
with also an eye on the clock maybe
we've got at this point the King is
still in the center
well they're not even taking
let's push
hmm they still went on with that
alrighty this is clearly collapsing now
yeah they resigned back to terminus okay
note to self what color are you playing
all right
well he was up there he was one of the
top dogs so I have ten thoughts having
your fun okay I got white shut up and
make a move shut up and make a move man
let's go with D for this one shouldn't
be too bad I think the Knights will sit
well here
and before any of that I want to
my opponent in the center okay so this
guy's look having a tough day at the
office
okay let's control this potential break
we're going to go with the Knight f3
before Knight g3 he has a better
influence on the center probably Knight
g3 here let's go with 93 I'm ready to
Castle now that this square is opened up
they went with castles cuz I go with
should I go with b4 or b3 I'm gonna go
with the beef or grab a little bit of
clean side space and maybe one day I go
here we're pulling very fast
let's recapture
castle right about now there we go rooks
are connected the bishops don't
necessarily have to move they're already
playing where does it gets filed for my
queen I want to come all the way back to
see one yeah let's do this
stop see five control F four
how about e4 rook e1 e for just d4
straight away let's get to you for in
straight away I have enough support for
it
maybe this
let's get that moving they're playing
very fast very fast okay here here we go
with the dark square Bishop he's flying
a knight on this square it might be
pretty good what about a push let's try
it
pawn takes and then they're in a pin ooh
go for this
that's an interesting way out or is it I
missing anything we takes this and I
have that move okay the night is there
to defend but I could take the night out
first and then after this move they're
in a pickle
to bishops but I'm winning material very
soon all right
so now there's holes everywhere on the
e-file isolated pawn can also take that
now let's not do that here and then
they're here
let's just post up right in the center
defended by my night clean takes pawn
rooks kind of repairs the structure but
maybe I don't want to see the rooks
sliding over here be looking for some
attack rook takes rook in the night here
how about we play a little bit more
simple let's strike at this pawn and
this one
a queen exchange I have an extra piece
they have two pawns but tough to get
them rolling with this Bishop here do
not even have a flight score I feel like
I should have some mating attack let's
start off with this rook here back rank
mate 135 where is this guy they just
resigned checking the sea views on the
top of the first page okay so we got to
win in there I have 12 with fire really
have to win out if I'm going to try to
get first here can't get too many games
in three Oh time control
18:16 13:12 is where I stand
okay
you
let's see who we get so the pack leader
is in a game right now
okay I got black what's unprotected
nothing
all right um here and then here I'm
playing as black I'm playing as black
maybe my opponent is going to not make a
move okay got to make a move within 25 I
think I want to start with this
already I have an idea to exchange off
my dark square bishop so let's go here
trying for this my bad guy could cut
that in let's go for it straightaway I
did say I mean if you've been following
on the high channel with the good and
bad bishops video I did this is really
like the top concept that's running
through my mind when I'm playing a 960
game so I'm okay if they try to hunt him
down
yeah okay if you're going to take and
help my rock out
it's basically how I view that
and I guess I'll be going without 6uu
and just drop that pond I don't see a
reason not to take them
okay well like it no let's not get too
fancy let's uh
let's just come all the way back I don't
know I would want to well maybe I could
have gone here maybe I should have gone
here too one day once I get castled on
the kingside I'd double up I should have
played here and then winding up a
sacrifice on this square though
I'm setting up so
and sneaky right now
backtick I'm setting up this is tempting
I know it is it's very tempting to do
that but I would have a slick move who
sees the slick move anybody see the
slick move in the chat they just gave up
their good Bishop
of a slick move in mind if they do this
Somebody Anybody quickly in the chat
who's gonna see it ah they're going
bonkers now I don't see anybody typing
it in the chat yes
pointing it out on c3 rook a one king
takes a knight here with the fork whoops
but as it is now they're just down
material do I still have something fancy
related related to that tactic let's
just defend some pawns love a piece
okay let's go here defend the pond
prepare to meet h5 with g5 thus bishop
sizes now his eyes are now open
where's the mate
right into threat they didn't and see
that one
right they resigned back to
and I got a 4 2 2 4 0 2 2 4 I'm at 16
it is possible
we'll catch up especially if I get
paired up against esta Chen who is no
and it just started a game gaining a lot
of points as well
nearly 300 points for these top two is
23 oh this guy this guy just uh finished
I think I might be getting paired up
with this guy Tiago let's see
twenty two minutes left
yes
is extremely important I'm playing as
black what's unprotected I'm getting
preserved unprotected unprotected the
rook pawns are unprotected this position
bishops are already fee and cut out that
I already have a similar position at
least with the knights and bishops and
the previous game I'm playing is black
my opponent is still just thinking this
one through really paranoid Oh what's
this about Wow did it make a move
I don't know what to think they do that
on purpose just to hear my reaction
that's a bit odd somebody who just got
in first place okay team white what's
unprotected quickly this guy is he going
to be vulnerable I don't think so let's
start with this rook in the center
supports a phone in the center one of
these two squares rooks on d1 or e1 pawn
advance okay he's my bad guy got that
first move in I think my pieces should
try it some nice squares
with this guy here they at the other
night here maybe this was more to the
point okay hang on
I like this move this is my bad bishop
but
I really want to do that
they can always Castle kingside would
they have time to do that though
i D would ruin their
a possibility to Castle queenside
ah
with this stay a little bit flexible
maybe I fee and cut out go g3 that move
let's go here
here I have this
then straight away I might want to get
my clean out by way of H 3 H 2 H 3 and
Queen H 2 H 4 weakens
G 4 and the night just a moment away
making use of that square so probably
Bishop to e2 I have him as a defender
his position could be challenged soon
with c5c for probably a good idea to
just get castled have my rook there to
defend i don't want to rely upon my
knight as a defender like this it may be
c4 soon
like I could get
that made
maybe now that this night can't get to
this square I'm a little bit out more
okay with h4 let's go to h4 because I
like that I have h3 as a check
what's that move about so they're not
going to Castle kingside huh let's
insert this check they're shooting for
this advance but I have everything on it
and now where to go it's my rook what's
going on way down on time let's go with
this truck and then shoot for c4 maybe
the B file opens up that's why I went
with the C Rukn now they just castled
queenside yes they just Castle queenside
my rooks are opposite their king this
pawn is pinned and now things are
opening up in my favour I'm pretty sure
you have some really good coordination
in this position the Queen is not
playing still stuck in the corner
I'm just looking for this kind of break
c5 I'd love to see this pawn exchanged
off these guys are split this rook his
eyes open up that much more minute ten
we'll do it potential pins on the B file
one of these two is pinned
what's that night up to
okay let's take not sure why though why
did I take yeah let's just take and try
a 45 something simple keep the pieces as
is and just try to break down the
structure a little bit III was thinking
about this kind of stuff but I figured
h5 and here and maybe Bishop d6 I don't
think my queen there's still too much
traffic on the board I'm just going for
that all right look I got a play on this
wing could maybe first captured and then
I would have the e5 square watch out for
this guy he's pretty dangerous but he's
not yet combined with any major piece
evening out on the clock I'm breaking
down their King position much faster I
believe Bishop a3 I can meet with Bishop
to b2 let's just take him out I don't
think I even need to recapture here
let's just crash through against their
king this is far more important
to hide behind my pond then their
bishops dead no now he's a tap-in and I
could just look to pile up on the pins
piece yeah it should be winning this is
covered bishop said twice Bishop f3
threatens the knight Knight c5 it's all
falling into place no let's still add
some more fuel to that Bishop and now
Knight c5 I'm just hammering away at the
pinned piece now two rooks a bishop
currently and now Knight and this is
just broken down now 1 2 3 1 2 3 4
takes yeah they're going to take steaks
yeah I have to give up their queen I
guess we'll take with the bishop first I
don't think it really matters
you
I guess I should have just captured with
the rook but
either way lending some more material no
mate
and they're down on time back to
tournament 15 minutes left
have my chances after that bonehead move
of not moving
so let's see 26 24 24 I have fire along
with esta Chen who has yet to slip up
okay 15 minutes left
I'm playing his black what's unprotected
this guy and he could be struck out by
the Queen similarly if this pawn move
strikes here now that I even want to
take them though let's uh let's put upon
in the center I'm always so nervous I'm
not going to make that first move
I was nervous before that that and that
even happened to me and now it's even
worse
okay let's activate this guy because
he's
kinda bad here here here I want to be a
little bit careful of backing up because
how is he going to play might have to do
something like this just so both
diagonals are you know so that both
diagonals remain open for my bishops
here in the Knight to d7 they may try
for this f6 here okay we can't castle
just yet how about this and then shoot
for this move can they strike here soon
I don't see how this Knight doesn't do
it here what is he striking at here what
is he striking in nothing I should be
too concerned with so I'm looking for
this maybe I could try to hunt down the
light square bishop
he's the bad [ __ ]
but he's definitely aggressively posted
um let's try for that I don't think I'd
be castling on this wing anyhow scrap
some space with my pawns
you and then here even
I could exchange
I don't know that I want to work around
that night
okay this is going to look a little bit
weird but I'm going to maybe shoot for
this advance one day
and let's go here one thing I like is
that these two-pound advances the
position in the center I don't think at
least can be cracked open so easily I'm
shooting for this f6 Knight f7 King side
castles also the C pawn can't help out
just yet because the knight can't move
if I capture them there's this and maybe
c3 d4
one minute 20
twelve minutes left in the tournament
clock clean they're heading for this
advance let's still go with this they're
ready to coordinate some on f7 or not
okay let's just defend my center point a
little bit more create a new square for
my night I would be in the pen if I
Castle kingside okay they really they
can't do this just yet my bishops in a
pinch so they might throw their King in
the corner
they're just giving a bishop up okay
make my life a little bit easier I think
here now I could get this in what I
wanted to do click this idea
now let's strike in the center
definitely take with the pun okay maybe
I grabbed some space pawn takes pawn as
a threat just scoot over clean here
clean here
let's go here I think this is a
inconvenience to the
the structure and how about yeah let's
go let's go here I guess thought about
this but maybe a four or this still F
four stops any potential pins against my
pawn if the Queen goes to this square
that's a good move that's a good move
maybe I should have yeah maybe this was
this is not well-timed although can I
still support this let's try for it I
don't want the night to have
hmm
let's shoot for this move the bishop
punch I want to get c5 and open his eyes
they're playing without the light square
bishop I forgot about that
to note that so let's maybe go here
first and then look for this they're
still in the pin 15 second mark are they
drop they're clean
just open it up their night both of
their nights are boxed out by my pawns
I guess we'll just triple up
pen
here on this I have
to the pin now they're way down on time
and I'm going to get that one and with
that where do I stand
ooh I have my chance both at 2800 it's
white hang on
let's get a move in there
9:28 but neither those players have fire
let's see I'm just going to support my
Center open my bishops eyes night here
this is a vulnerable square
start with this
he's in that nice section of the board
can i castle
talking side
I can't Castle kingside this rook has to
be
also kingside if I want to do that okay
let's weasel my bishop around get him
activated he's my bad bishop
put him here so that's what they're
looking to do okay I see I see I could
do this and then Castle kingside and I'm
going to go for that and yes okay so
things are starting to look a lot better
now you're really going to get that in
get my night out I have more control
over this
let's see this
instead of point the b2b seven squares
like I should be challenging okay my
bishop first let's exchange darts card
bishops and probably challenge this and
I'm doing it with this night because I
want to pieces on this okay things are
looking good I'm turning a fork they
might do this but they run into that
tactic and I want to get this in but the
bishops being annoying I'll probably use
probably know I could do this move oh
and I ran into another Fork though my
knight had two forks in mind or two
squares in mind okay
winning some material now and the next
phase is just I want to make certain
maybe this was more accurate now no I
feel like my nights shouldn't even
capture the rook let's try this first
the rook can't move to have seven to
save himself that would be me now this
is stupid though this was stupid
now let's take
let's go he
and now I have to make a
another move in order to get this and
what's there not going to do there's no
holes really that my opponent could take
advantage of this is simple enough move
I'm taking away so many squares from so
many other pieces here let's just grab a
little bit of space prior to going here
no you're going to take it the pun yeah
I'm going to take it the pun because not
to worry about night here and I'm
already strip throwing a strike a t7
which they dropped six minutes 11
seconds let's just stay on this dot this
file
I'll go look math exchanges I play fast
enough I could get this one in and one
more because the guy in first he's the
one that didn't make a move just go here
offer some exchanges
think I'll straighten out my pawns
okay let's go into pac-man mode take
this pawn and defend my beep on
you
um
[Music]
you
let's take this pond
don't like how I'm trying to convert
this
let's get a flight square
could sneak in here
just start pushing my upon I guess huh
at the 42nd mark this and this stuff is
the only thing I'm worried about but I
shouldn't be so much of an issue 26 huh
let's just go here for starters here and
I stopped night f4
you
still check-in
have the night returned first now he's
going to go here what am i doing
keep pressure here now maybe I push I
don't know what was really accomplished
with that last sequence of moves I mind
seeing the night drift over here and now
I could take this what's check
and then push there's this pin got the
night two seconds one second no time
come on back to tournament 333 Oh
this is the pack leader I have to beat
this guy in 30 seconds not happening and
he's going to play this time yeah
I could see I'd have to do it in 20
seconds it's not happening this is a
pretty normal in two
they can always known a fry they can
always want to fry probably the most
normal of positions I'm fine with that
exchange what they know no fry this is
super normal
supernormal
also
castle
I'm going to get on this long dog and
I'll know how this covered enough what
are they doing check on the long
diagonal on h2 here this is completely
winning but they're already at the point
where they could time burn ooh close to
getting mated they're getting mated on
the next move
don't know Anna Frye man look at how
close I was
right here that's making here this is me
no matter what this move is me
oh I only if I only went just a hair
faster come on Tiago you better resign
you better resign
you should not known a fry man don't
known a fry maybe there'll be a little
bit of delay a little bit of delay will
it happen will it happen maybe it won't
register on the tournament clock and
this one will still get in there we're
going to find out queen f2 scholars made
style I'm getting Nona fried here
oh I just went a little bit faster maybe
of course they okay I'm not touching
anything clean up - whether it's Knight
to e2 or King to f1 its mate next move
then I maybe even knocked out of podium
land if now these two players behind me
win that's possible as well let's see
what happens
is this
is it possible that I could still it
that it will register before you get the
trophies or is it really down to the
very second I probably is right down to
the very second I'm getting Kia cooed f2
Chen just one ah come on man no chance
it registers it registers getting the
word I was five seconds shy what can you
do
they allowed the mate but that one did
not register for the tournament
standings close so close a three-way tie
in there at 32 thiago is up there with
the Nona fryers of the world all right
so where do we at three thirty twos all
it's fire let's see some other pages why
not page two three four five and six
all right to the 58 of you good games Oh
ah
if I would have moved a little bit
faster in that last one maybe just maybe
I would have got it
you